cinquante mille chômeurs de plus c'est
un résultat décevant inattendu
d'ailleurs je dois le dire je vous
rappelle l'engagement de françois
hollande ces jeunes adhèrent ce pas la
courbe du chômage je ne serai pas
candidat c'est à lui maintenant de
prendre ses responsabilités par exclure
dit le candidat nicolas sarkozy ne fait
pas du buisson sans lui sont en essayant
d'aller sur les plates bandes du front
national pour l'affaiblir
si ça c'est pas de la balle gamme qu'est
ce que c'est qu'un amalgame
enfin je pose une question je vous
répond j'ai un cerveau j'ai pas besoin
d'être le poteau miser pour qui que ce
soit un livre à charge contre nicolas
sarkozy patrick buisson l'accusent
d'avoir parlé de valeurs orgueil en
colère et mauvais que son conseiller
premier réalité et deuxièmement je vous
dis le fond du fond du fond de ma pensée
cela n'a aucune importance politique
mais c'est une vraie déception humaine
par ses pulsions qu'il avait dit que
laquelle idéologique de nicolas sarkozy
est évident
j'en suis convaincu je pense que nicolas
sarkozy ne pense rien que c'est un très
bon candidat qui sent le vent électoral
mais que c'est un très mauvais président
qui ne sert pas les intérêts de la
france et on l'a vu malheureusement rien
aucune réconciliation possible avec
patrick buisson
c'est du pain ce sujet pour moi a promis
de démanteler la jungle de calais
définitivement là vous approuvez
j'imagine le problème si vous voulez
c'est que on va éparpillés la poussière
ouais ça veut dire que poussière oui ben
c'est la poussière
secrétaire clinton tout va bien eh bien
je veux que vous soyez heureuse c'est
très important pour moi
en région provence alpes côte d'azur
quand j'ai pu sur les actes mais c'est
autour de 10 millions des choses ça vous
dit deux millions d'habitants wii va
peut-être un peu plus que ça je sais pas
combien d'habitants région provençale
mais je n'ai pas eu d'offre examen je
l'étais y en a cinq
vous avez soutenu la guerre en irak
avant l'invasion
c'est faux je n'ai pas soutenu la guerre
en et 2002 en fait trump a soutenu
l'intervention en irak avant qu'elle ne
commence et il a fallu attendre plus
d'un an après pour qu'ils changent de
position qui n'a ni le look ni
l'endurance absolument pas l'endurance
nécessaires pour être présidente de
notre pays comme mend tamana quand il
aura voyagé dans 112 pays négocier un
accord de cessez le feu
la libération des six ans et l'auvergne
belle opportunité dont l'une est même
passé à témoigner devant le congrès il
pourra me parler dandurand que maire de
locminé grégoire super c'est un des
premiers parrainage que j'ai acquis ça
s'est passé au mois de mai sur un capot
de voiture
la photo a été prise dimanche dernier
audi vous allez bien ça se trouve à
bobigny en seine-saint-denis et
franchement je trouve assez cool ça
françois fillon j'ai signé de parrainage
sur le capot d'une voiture s'était pas
avec nathalie sous le capot de la
voiture